the winners and new champions of dancing
with the stars
are caitlyn and arnhem
tyra what did it feel like for you for
the first time
to have that big pause to announce
the winner of dancing with the stars i'm
obsessed with the pause by the way
like but i'm paused pause
i'm serving pause i am like i want
america to be like
say it say it say it say it so like the
pause is
everything and then you gave a gasp as
well a gasp before caitlyn's name what
was the yes
the gasp was the academy awards gasp you
know
because i honestly i didn't know if it
was going to be like caitlyn or
neve so either would have been a guest
because they both kind of deserved it
you know they both were so amazing
so were you really surprised how were
you in the judges feeling ahead of the
finale did you have any idea tell me how
you felt yeah
i mean i had a feeling that caitlyn
would go very far tonight you know she's
just so like
on it and the judges just had an issue
with her not attacking and hitting it
but after she got that critique then she
was attacking and hitting it
um so i i knew she would go far i just
didn't know if it would
who and the who would be the final final
so there's the academy award
whoa so what do you think did the right
person win
this season oh i think she did really
good i really think she did good
and you know she also wanted it so badly
you know she was very vulnerable she
shared a lot of herself i think america
voted for somebody that wasn't just a
great dancer but somebody that was
vulnerable and showed that she has
challenges and issues just like
everybody else
so tyro we have loved your outfit
changes every week
i'm gonna ask you and we're gonna do the
math later do you have an idea of how
many outfit changes you did
all season oh my gosh i have no idea
okay 11 episodes average
two per episodes would take us to 22.
one episode i only did one change that
would take me to 21 but there were about
two episodes that i did
three changes so that would take me to
22 23.
i'm gonna say 23. okay quick math from
the business woman i love it we'll see
um so this was your first season how do
you
feel about everything that happened with
you as host anything you'd do
differently
and will we see you again i
had so much fun um i think what i would
do differently a lot what has to do with
the costume changes
um toward the end we we realized we had
to write down like
off the head take the hat off then the
earrings then like it's written down
so they're yelling it to me as we go
because there are a couple of instances
where i'm holding my clothes up
and hosting live tv and not everybody
necessarily knew that um so that's one
thing another thing is um more
more comfy shoes um i had my second and
third toe go
numb on me for five days from last
week's outfit because those shoes were
not comfy
um yeah yeah
so okay okay well that's all fixable um
i i have to ask you because this was
such a landmark change for you to come
on and you've just crushed it
did you ever hear from tom or from aaron
have you spoken to them at all about how
this scene yeah
or anything no i i never spoke to them
like directly
um but i think there was like kind of
like messages and love like publicly and
tom did some very
supportive beautiful things um the first
thing that i did is when
i was announced and it was in a press
release i made sure
that i said his name um and said that
there was big shoes to fill and i will
do my best
um and then i remember tweeting him and
saying yo if i mess up like damn me and
just let me know
but i haven't had a personal
conversation with him but i still feel
him
fill him in that ballroom okay so no dms
he never said hey you messed up he never
said yo boo what's up
so will we see you back next season will
you host again
i don't know we shall see i don't know i
had a good time we'll see
we shall see would you do you want to
i don't know we'll see tyra
okay i i need all the tyra moments now
i'm used to you coming out entering i
need to see it i know
right like those 23 or 24
outfits okay well they do come back i
think they might be
we might get up to 30 if i go back
outfit what needs to happen for you to
come back
i don't know yes you do yes you do
you totally do okay um
well it's certainly you know i know how
time-consuming it is you've got a little
one at home you've got family what's it
been like to balance all this and how
has your family been supporting you yeah
oh my family's super supportive my son
is obsessed with dancing with the stars
he sings the song to me
um he he's now remixing it with nxs
nxs uh uh
i'm like wait is my son like dj puff
daddy or something
what are you doing like he's naturally
remixing the song um
my mom was the first person to ever tell
me to watch dancing with the stars so
she's so proud
to see me host the show my mom gets on
me when i come
home we live together now and uh she
tells me like sometimes i'm hunting when
i have on something strapless
she's like yeah you did good but she was
hunching and i'm like thanks ma keeping
it real
um it's been it's been really fun for my
family for us to
be a part of it well i have to wrap with
you but two more quick questions first
nellie just told me that if he'd known
that caitlyn and neve had dance
backgrounds like they did he never would
have signed up for the show
i wanted your reaction to that oh wow
i did not know that so he's is he a
little
like not fair probably is what he's
maybe feeling he said the competitive
side of him was a little salty yes
oh but you know what but no one had
nellie's swag there was something about
nelly
on that dance floor where you felt like
he was grooving and you just wanted to
like groove with him
so that was his unfair advantage of just
having that swag
and being able to be in an arena with 15
000 people yelling his name and he
commanding that stage
and he commanded he wasn't a super
technical ballroom dancer
but he had that unfair advantage of that
all right i like that
all right i gotta wrap with you but my
last question uh what is just your
message to the fans both
the fans who you know gave quite a lot
of critiques this season
and the ones who cheered this season
with all of its changes on what do you
tell everybody
i have to tell everybody thank you for
watching we broke a lot of records when
it comes
to the ratings for this show
and yes there was change but the change
meant a hell of a lot of big ratings
so in the end you know this is a
business and that's what matters
is making sure that people are coming
and new people are coming
and change is a good thing okay any
dream cast members for next season
um yeah colin kaepernick oh
okay yes it can be really interesting
[Music]